the Expo features giant tractors and
combine Harvesters and multi-billion
dollar corporations that manufacture all
sorts of farming equipment not to
mention a full line of brush shredders
new technologies are changing how
farming is done we are really at the
cost of a revolution in agricultural
technology and that has a lot of
implications for food and food
production an example is Monarch
tractors fully electric multiple camera
and sensor equipped multi-use machine a
fleet of these can be operated
autonomously without drivers by a single
farmer acting as a controller it stores
data on crops and soil conditions among
many other variables farmers are
essentially figuring out how to feed the
world's growing population at a time
when they have less resources so we need
to use less of these resources but yet
still produce more food than ever before
so that is the challenge we all have and
that's where technology has a role to
play and Technology we firmly believe
can bridge that Gap the challenge to
Global agriculture is immense right now
there are eight billion people on Earth
345 million of whom are considered
acutely food insecure by mid-century the
population will grow to about 10 billion
and global warming is threatening crop
yields a NASA study projects World maze
production will drop nearly a quarter by
2100 due to global heating the un's
world food organization estimates that
by 2050 the world will have to increase
its food production by 70 percent in
order to feed an ever-growing population
one way to close the gap is to farm and
consume with less waste right now if we
were to take away food waste and food
losses we would right away increase our
food production by about 30 percent
that's just what this futuristic fruit
picking machine from tevel Technologies
does autonomous drones determine exactly
when the fruit is ripe pick it by
suction and send it on its way to the
market increased production less waste a
merger of technology and farming to feed
a hungry planet
Rob Reynolds Al Jazeera Tulare
California